it's really important that i do this
story today uh before we get
uh sucked into really unreasonable and
naive expectations about how the next
couple of years are going to go we need
to reset
our expectations for the next couple of
years and this should help
some have been wondering some have been
asking me emailing me david what happens
to these anti-trump republicans when joe
biden wins
what happens to the lincoln project what
happens to kasich what happens to romney
do they keep working with democrats do
they support biden's agenda
what happens and the answer is no to all
of the above
i have two quick clips to play for you
today
which will in no time at all disabuse
you
of the notion that these anti-trump
republicans are
our friends now to be very clear if you
take an
anti-trump republican and you remove
trump what do you have left
it's called a republican okay they
become just
republicans when you remove trump from
the equation here is mitt romney
strong principled anti-trump republican
right
telling jake tapper on cnn his
priorities now that trump are gone
are blocking the green new deal
keeping gas coal and oil
and blocking medicare for all and
blocking any tax increases take a look
i'm not going to talk about my vote
that's in the rearview mirror i'm going
to talk now about
how i can work with the new president i
i know he's
on the other side of the aisle but i
want to make sure that we conservatives
keep on fighting to make sure that we
don't have a green new deal
we don't get rid of gas and coal and
oil that we don't have a medicare for
all plan
put in place so we don't raise taxes on
american enterprise that would kill the
economy so
look i i i congratulate him but i'm not
going to
put aside conservative principles we're
going to fight for the things that we
believe in
so he was against trump principled
voted even to convict trump on
impeachment on one of the two counts
his policies are still awful and now his
priority is blocking the things
that joe biden says he's going to do
mitt romney
now that joe biden will be president
immediately returns
to making his focus preventing us from
putting policies in place that would be
good for the environment
and good for people and good for the
economy these are not our friends and i
was wrong because i previously said the
day biden is inaugurated they go by
back to being their nonsensical selves i
underestimated
the day after biden was called the
winner they went back to being their
nonsensical selves here's another one
reasonable anti-trump republican john
kasich supported biden
he goes on cnn and says joe biden won
great
now biden needs to do what republicans
want and make sure
that the left of the democratic party
isn't listened to
and kasich even goes on to say that the
far left almost cost biden the election
and right on cue i have joked that they
would do this
john kasich actually brings up you know
we've got big debt problems to solve
it is beyond parody i told you
you're ready for them to talk about the
debt again right and and
right on cue john kasich is doing it now
is the time
for democrats and i believe joe biden
will do this to begin to listen to what
the other half the country has had to
say
but we have to listen to what those
folks those republicans
all across this country has had to say
the best thing that's happened
to joe biden is the fact that the united
states senate is either going to be
republican or very close
and the far left can push him as hard as
they want and frankly the democrats have
to make it clear to the far left
that they almost cost him this election
and that congresswoman from virginia
warned the democrats you want to talk
about defunding the police
you'll have no support and i think this
is an opportunity for buying to
talk about you know the center right and
the center-left of this country and what
can be achieved because we have enormous
problems with debt
social security medicare health care
little steps
little steps one other thing one
democrat told me
at some point if they'd have been more
clear in rejecting the hard left
they would have appealed more to
americans who i believe
essentially live in the middle so i
think actually he's in a better position
today
because being pulled from the left isn't
going to work
so they are doing every single thing
that republicans always
do they've learned nothing they've
changed nothing
from this trump experience during trump
some of them oppose
trump biden wins now it's resist the
influence from the hard
left we've got to deal with the debt
we've got to find
common ground which by the way when they
win
they never have to find common ground
common ground they want when they lose
democrats have catered to the middle
like kasich says for decades
and now biden won thanks to the activism
of the left in places like georgia and
others
so the last thing joe biden should be
doing
is listening to the people first of all
he shouldn't be listening to kasich or
romney
and he certainly shouldn't be listening
to the people kasich and romney
want biden to listen to it's i'm i have
like whiplash
from how quickly these republicans go
right back to their tired old lines i
told you it would happen and it has